heavily armed soldiers in the streets
after three days of protest a daily
routine in Zimbabwe is Capitol Herrera
shops are closed public institutions are
not working people are desperate justing
it just going to wake assuming as if
everything is normal
why president Amazon Managua is an
extended trip to Russia and the Davos
meeting to search for funds authorities
back at home clamped down on the
protesters on Wednesday police arrested
pastor Mahavira the pastor and prominent
critic of the government is accused of
supporting street protests
they're alleging that he has incited
violence through cheat and other forms
of social media the government suspect
that the mob was political opposition is
behind the violence but the opposition
said that spearing living conditions
have left ordinary Zimbabweans no choice
but to protest it is the cost of living
that is adjusted which has caused people
to complain fuel prices unavailability
food prices and availability lack of
jobs this week the government hiked fuel
prices after announcing a national
shortage the barber's fuel became the
most expensive in the world
street protests have diminished but
there has been a coordinated
stay-at-home protest organized by the
country's trade unions aimed at
protesting Daiya living conditions and
no end in sight
you